all right we're going to look at an
incredible contrast that is taking place
now within the republican party in the
last segment we looked at what's going
on in the democratic party joe biden
approval voter sentiment about who
should run in 2024. let's now look at
the republican party we have on the one
hand a stunning new poll which we will
look at which shows that half of
republicans are ready to abandon trump
they want someone else they're ready to
go
and on the other hand donald trump is
still the most popular republican
and every indication is that if there is
a contested republican primary involving
donald trump it's going to be absolutely
and utterly insane so let's start with
the first piece first half of republican
voters are ready to abandon donald trump
far from consolidating his support
writes the new york times the former
president appears weakened in his party
especially with younger and
college-educated republicans governor
ron desantis of florida is the most
popular alternative and that's something
you know if you've been watching the
show because we've been talking about it
as donald trump weighs whether to open
an unusually early white house campaign
that very same new york times sienna
poll which we cited earlier in terms of
joe biden
and democratic voters shows that trump's
post-presidential quest to consolidate
support within the gop has left him
weakened
nearly half of the party's primary
voters
seek someone different for president in
2024 and a significant number are vowing
to abandon trump if he wins the
nomination
trump appears to have deepened fault
lines among republicans during his
year-long revenge tour a clear majority
of primary voters under 35
64
as well as 65 percent of those with at
least a college degree a leading
indicator of preferences in the donor
class told pollsters they would vote
against trump in a presidential primary
reasons include trump's conduct on
january 6th
um
overall trump maintains his primacy in
the party in a hypothetical matchup
against five other republican
presidential rivals 49 of primary voters
say they would support him for a third
nomination so we're going to d we're
going to get more into that in a moment
but here are uh some of these
interesting numbers so if a republican
2024 primary were held today who would
you vote for 49 say donald trump
51 say someone else but as you can see
no individual alternative
gets more than 25 percent and that to a
great degree
tells us a lot about the potential
dynamics of a very fractured 2024
republican primary and we are going to
get to that now some interesting um
demographic numbers
um trump does much better significantly
better notably better with men rather
than women 52 versus 45
and trump does significantly better with
those who have no college degree in fact
among those with a college degree trump
loses to desantis 32 to 28 but among
those with no college degree trump more
than doubles ron desantis 58 to 21.
those are
extraordinarily
notable and interesting numbers now one
other aspect to this
is that desantis has not run for
president before
um and so when you look at you know
is polling roughly seven percent in in
this particular poll mike pence is
polling between
five and ten depending on which
demographic group these are known
entities desantis is not as known and in
fact a quarter of republicans said they
don't even have an opinion of desantis
yet because they don't know enough about
him those who know who desantis is
really like him unfortunately a quarter
don't but that's actually a really good
thing for ron desantis because it
suggests at least that theoretically
that as more republicans come to know
desantis
he may be influential uh in getting
people over to his side and later in
today's show we have a voicemail that
asks sort of an important question about
desantis versus trump uh should desantis
and trump face off in a primary
the poll suggested that support from fox
news could prove crucial and this could
be you know i think it is fair to say
that at this point fox news has been
weakened from uh its prior strength
and it has in part been weakened because
of competitors like newsmax and others
it's in part been weakened because
donald trump has been uh significantly
antagonistic to fox news over the last
year and a half
but uh trump holds a 62 to 26 advantage
over desantis among fox news viewers
but among floridians it's 16 points
closer if they use a different primary
source of news if you don't watch fox
you're much less likely to support trump
over the desantis and that would be uh a
really a really critical thing so half
of republicans again with all of these
things you can look at it glass half
full or glass half empty depending on
who you are
one perspective would be
half of republicans
want someone other than trump that's not
particularly good for a former president
on the other hand
trump doubles every other potential
competitor right now
and would easily win a primary if it
were to be held today
uh and you can
decide for yourself which of those two
perspectives is more relevant or more
valid and um that is the new york times
poll
let's now go and talk about what the
primary dynamics could be
i never have time to read all of the
non-fiction books that i want to read
our sponsor blinkist has solved the
problem for me in a way because blinkist
takes thousands of the best and newest
nonfiction books extracts the key
takeaways and then you can either read
or listen to them in 15 minutes i read
all the time i love narrative nonfiction
i read economics i read all these
different things as i said before i
would love to have time to read more
history i just don't right now
especially with a newborn you should see
what's going on in the middle of the
night but
uh with blinkist i was able to read in
fact i listened to a 15-minute audio
version of putin's people by katherine
belton with what's going on in ukraine
and russia i just wanted more history
how did
in fact the book is called how the kgb
took back russia and then took on the
west i wanted to learn how did this
adversarial situation develop
what is the history of the putin kgb
coming to power etc i did not have time
to read that book in full but in just 15
minutes with blinkist i was able to get
all of the uh key points which now i can
use when i am talking about ukraine and
russia and have more context blinkist
has condensed over 5000 non-fiction
books in 27 categories try blinkist free
for seven days and get twenty five
percent off a subscription at
blinkist.com pacman the link is down
below